[Musique]
bonjour je suis ravi de vous retrouver
ici depuis bruxelles depuis le coeur du
parlement européen dans ce nouveau
numéro d' europe hebdo nous allons
ouvrir ensemble les portes de l'europe
et voici le programme de cette émission
une émission spéciale puisque david ça
se lit le président du parlement
européen est notre invité nous
reviendrons bien sûr avec lui sur cette
crise sanitaire et économique sans
précédent que le monde et l'europe
traversent avec cette réponse européenne
ce plan de relance qui se dessine porté
par le couple franco allemand
mais nous reviendrons sur bien d'autres
sujets le bric site l'état de droit mais
aussi quel avenir pour l'europe et pour
commencer retour donc sur les 12
premiers mois de ce parlement européen
élu en mai 2019 une année chargée et
mouvementée c'est un sujet de béatrice
faisant
[Musique]
c'était il y a un an
l'eurodéputé italien
sociaux-démocrates david sassoli est élu
avec 345 voix à la présidence nous
connaissons des tournants chômage des
jeunes migration changement climatique
révolution numérique des nouveaux
équilibres mondiaux qui voit le jour
nouveaux équilibres mondiaux
nouveau visage européen notamment côté
français avec une europe plus clivée
vous avez finalement servi les marchés
et vous ne manquerez pas à nombre de nos
peuples et concitoyens européens pour
retourner dans votre paradis fiscal vos
amis les multinationales que vous avez
aidé pendant le luxe l'x vous souhaite
une joyeuse retraite avec ce cadeau
merci beaucoup départ de jean claude
juncker est arrivé de la commission von
der leyen dont certaines candidatures
sont écartés par les eurodéputés comme
la française sylvie goulard
à une clean autre départ marquant les 60
13 parlementaires britanniques le 31
janvier
[Musique]
de nouveaux visages des institutions
européennes renouveler en profondeur
break site green deal ou encore salaire
minimum européen une année sociale et
écologique riche en perspectives stoppé
net par la crise du coronavirus ce qui
n'a pas empêché le nouveau parlement
européen de travail et même sans siéger
et je suis ravi de vous accueillir ici
sur ce plateau david sassoli vous êtes
président du parlement européen vous
êtes italien vous êtes social démocrate
et je précise que vous êtes un ancien
journaliste et vous avez été lues ici
pour la première fois eurodéputé en 2009
voici pour la carte de visite bienvenus
bonjour on vient de le voir en images
quelle année vous attendiez à cela
mais cela c'est de l'histoire de cette
année le break sic la formation de la
commission du parlement
la crise de l'aco vide à présent je suis
heureux de constater qu'il ya un an les
thèmes qui sont importants pour
reconstruire l'union européenne était
déjà indiqué à l'époque je pense
notamment au parc vers la capacité que
nous devons avoir de miser sur un
continent qui doit être à la pointe de
la lutte contre les émissions de co2 je
pense que c'est là l'un des grands
sujets que nous devons défendre pour
l'avenir on y reviendra mais on va
reparler de cette crise sanitaire qui
après avoir démarré en chine s'est
abattue sur l'europe l'union européenne
at-elle été à la hauteur
jusqu'à ce jour il ya
de nombreuses hésitations car beaucoup
de pays ne pensais pas qu'il serait
aussi
profondément touchées par cette pandémie
mais ensuite il faut le dire la réponse
a été et communale a été
égale pour tous et l'on a même pris
conscience qu aucun pays ne s'en
sortiraient seul et c'est ainsi que nous
sommes aujourd'hui en train de réfléchir
à des réponses communes contrairement à
ce qui s'est passé en 2008 ou en 2012
avec les crises traversées par la grèce
suite au lehman brothers aujourd'hui on
se rend compte que l'europe de donner
une réponse commune et ça c'est une des
leçons à tirer peut-être de la crise
sanitaire à la nécessité notamment d'une
europe de la santé au travers peut-être
d'une agence européenne de santé oui il
faut nous sortir de cette crise avec une
europe qui renforce surtout la santé des
femmes et des hommes il nous faut une
politique européenne et des normes
communes
nous devons renforcer notre modèle
social
et n'oublions pas en effet que au cours
de ces derniers mois aucun citoyen
européen ne s'est retrouvé sans prise en
charge donc bien d'autres pays les soins
et les traitements étaient trop onéreux
ou les gens n'avaient pas accès à la
santé publique mais nous nous avons des
forces que nous devons tourner qu'elle
nous devons miser encore plus c'est le
cas de notre modèle social qui est
différent de tous les autres et la crise
n'est pas terminée il ya de nouveaux
foyers de contamination qui émerge un
peu partout en europe parce que vous
êtes inquiet de la deuxième vague est ce
que l'europe est mieux préparée
oui nous devons être très prudents être
très attentif
nous devons mener nos activités
économiques pour une relance mais dans
la plus grande prudence
les risques sont toujours présents nous
ne sommes pas encore sortis
nous ne savons pas ce qui arrivera après
l'été durant la crise 1 le parlement a
continué de fonctionner les eurodéputés
depuis leur domicile ont pu pour la
première fois voté à distance c'était
important que durant la crise malgré la
crise le parlement européen continue de
fonctionner 6
parce que pour nous la réponse devait
être une réponse démocratique par
conséquent les institutions ne pouvait
pas s'arrêter
nous avons donc maintenu le parlement
ouvert nous avons fait fonctionner
l'union européenne
parce que les
mesures adoptées par la commission le
système show
l'aide sanitaire les interventions qui
ont été faites toutes les mesures ont
été adoptées par le parlement et donc le
parlement a permis à l'union européenne
de fonctionner et ça a été une grande
réussite pour nous on nous a demandé
comment on nous étions arrivés ailleurs
le congrès américain le parlement
brésilien voulait savoir comment nous
nous en étions sortis avec quelle
technologie et pour la première fois
nous sommes parvenus à adopter des
règlements en permettant à tous les
députés de participer en provenance de
27 pays différents alors depuis un les
sessions plénières ont repris ici à
bruxelles mais pas à strasbourg pour
éviter de trop nombreux déplacements on
peut le comprendre les sessions
plénières est ce qu'elles vont reprendre
à strasbourg et si oui quand et nous y
retournerons septembre en septembre nous
retrouverons à strasbourg et nous en
sommes ravis parce que c'est l'une de
nos villes sièges que nous avons dû
quitter au cours de ces derniers mois si
difficile difficile pour la ville de
strasbourg même mais nous voulons y
retourne et nous y retournerons
septembre
étant prudent bien sûr avec des
nouvelles modalités qui nous permettront
d'être présents physiquement et à
distance
mais la plénière de septembre s'est
décidée aura lieu à strasbourg avec la
crise sanitaire il est la crise
économique un qui s'en suit ce plan de
relance porté par le couple
franco-allemand 750 milliards d'euros
sur la table dont 500 e milliards
d'euros de dette directe qui serait
financé par un endettement commun est-ce
que vous soutenez ce plan de relance oui
ça va c'est un plan très important où il
est très important que l'on ait pu
apporter une telle réponse avec un plan
qui nous placent tout sur un plaider
pied d'égalité donc avec un endettement
commun c'est d'ailleurs un grand sujet
du passé et nous voyons aujourd'hui que
c'est un mécanisme qui serait utile
et sonia
l'année chez sita il nous faut à présent
s'il ya eu europe et au delà du christ
aux finances estimant avoir une décision
du conseil européen de cette
semaine il faut notamment que le budget
de l'union européenne soit plus
ambitieux sans coupe je pense que nos
concitoyens ne comprendraient pas que
l'on réduise le budget consacré à la
recherche alors que aujourd'hui avec
cette crise de la commis 19 nous nous
rendons compte que nous avons besoin de
plus de recherches pour protéger la vie
des citoyens alors concernant ce plan de
relance il y a des réticences autour de
cette dette commune de la part de
plusieurs états membres le danemark les
pays-bas la suède notamment je vous
propose d'écouter les arguments des
manuels macron pour les convaincre
mais les fameux pays frugaux dont nous
parlons il faut jamais l'oublier ce sont
des pays qui sont bénéficiaires nets du
fonctionnement du marché unique
ce sont des pays pour qu'ils
participaient à un espace commun de
prospérité et des changes rapporte
beaucoup beaucoup plus qu'à d'autres et
donc ça n'est pas leur intérêt de voir
certains membres et en particulier des
marchés importants de l'économie
européenne être affecté
c'est donc de la solidarité d'avoir ces
transferts mais c'est aussi un intérêt
bien compris
ce mécanisme d'endettement commun c'est
la solidarité européenne qui est en jeu
il faut réduire le fossé le fossé entre
le nord et le sud de l'europe que la
crise sanitaire est encore creusé je
rends compte que je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec le président macro
mobilezone et nous devons réduire les
distances entre le nord et le sud et en
même temps il faut que les gouvernements
nationaux soient prêts à soutenir un
plan de relance qui serait d'application
dans tout l'espace européen est ce que
vous êtes optimiste qu'un accord soit
trouvé entre les 27 états membres j'aime
bien ce sont des négociations nous
sommes confiants de pas retenir la
meilleure des solutions un plan de
relance initié un par le couple franco
allemand le président français qui
depuis son élection en 2007 ne cesse de
se déclarer pro-européen et prône le
renforcement de la souveraineté
européenne vous êtes convaincus par les
mots et emmanuel macron par son
engagement européen
si si je suis très convaincu je pense
vraiment que et la ciculation né sous la
vita des singles assurance vie des états
membres ces deux nuits européennes parce
qu'il faut faire face à des défis
mondiaux à des dynamiques
internationales
l'économie je pense qu'aucun état membre
d'être en mesure de se défendre seul je
pense que ces mesures peuvent être une
protection pour tous le pays alors il ya
l'allemagne qui vient de prendre la
présidence tournante de l'union
européenne l'occasion pour angela merkel
de venir présenter les objectifs pour
les six mois à venir devant le parlement
européen et pour la chancelière
allemande être européen c'est aussi
partager des valeurs on me dit une
facture aux 4 mitsubishi précise
mousseline fort hugh grant et les mêmes
traces groupe
d'asseoir ndiwa price d'un jeu 10 gros
tracteur amgen rationnant europa art
groen
menchov caritas fait fausse route en
europe haram side of new media grichting
noisy a causé
une pandémie danny 26 une démocratie qui
risque en europe as in a
strange
adventures in game show
bright
lights out 10 arômes soft de groupe très
jeune en europe à
la chancelière allemande elle rappelle
une des fondations l'europe ses valeurs
ce qui soulève forcément la question de
ceux qui portent atteinte à l'état droit
et là on tourne vers la hongrie le
premier ministre viktor orban neal a
décrété un état d'urgence très décrié
durant la crise sanitaire une soupe
troyen en quelque sorte les pleins
pouvoirs encore une provocation à
l'endroit de l'union européenne qui
semble assez impuissante à réagir
fermement à tout à fait d'accord avec la
chancelière allemande merkel devant
protéger mais dans un cadre de valeurs
qui sont nos valeurs et cerise sur ce
point il faut faire preuve de vigilance
et de contrôle alors concernant la
hongrie le parlement européen n'a eu de
cesse d'alerter les institutions sur la
détérioration de l'état de droit il ya
plus de deux ans la procédure de
sanction de l'article 7 du traité sur le
qui peut aboutir à une suspension du
droit de vote de la hongrie a été
déclenché mais malgré cela l'europe elle
a quand même du mal à faire respecter
ces valeurs sur l'ensemble du territoire
européen avec peut-être des tentations
autoritaires
nous nous demandons que document de
m il faut que les fonds du cadre
financier pluriannuel de l'union impose
des conditions en matière de respect de
l'état de droit et de notre côté nous
attendons que du côté du conseil y ait
des indications claires parce que pour
le parlement ce serait difficile à
accepter de ne pas avoir de règles en
matière de respect de l'état de droit
donc j'invite le conseil être très clair
et à suivre le cap indiqué par la
chancelière merkel autres pays
régulièrement sous le feu des critiques
pour des violations libertés publiques
c'est là c'est la pologne les élections
présidentielles elles viennent d'avoir
lieu et le président sortant le
conservateur en place jude à a été réélu
de justesse au détriment du candidat
libéral pro-européen est ce que c'est
une chance manquée pour les polonais de
peut-être renouer un dialogue plus
serein avec le reste de l'europe
je ne lis jamais commenter le résultat
des élections mais ce que je constate
c'est que dans la société polonaise on
voit qu'il y à une poussée européiste
alors les pro européens n'ont pas
remporté les élections mais il ya une
poussée de ce mouvement et je pense que
le nouveau gouvernement devra tenir
compte de cela il ya beaucoup de jeunes
et une majorité des jeunes polonais et
des habitants de la pologne qui ont une
vocation européenne est ce que vous
constatez comme beaucoup une fracture
plus importante entre l'europe de l'est
et l'europe de l'ouest mon coming to you
graduellement je pense que comme on le
disait bien instant on doit tout faire
pour
rapprocher le nord et le sud mais
également l'est et l'ouest du continent
il ya de nombreuses questions qui
concernent certains pays et qui devrait
être comment dire d'être
[Musique]
affronter plus en profondeur je pense
qu'ils pourraient faire son l'union
europénne aujourd'hui
[Musique]
grand nombre de gouvernements devraient
faire preuve d'un peu plus de prudence
surtout lorsque l'on parle de valeurs
fondamentales
mais
les 27 états membres de l'union lequel
pourrait s'en sortir sans l'europe
actuellement il y en a qui a choisi de
sortir de l'union européenne c'est le
royaume uni et c'est une première depuis
la le début de la construction
européenne les négociations autour du
bric site elles sont au point mort même
si le premier ministre boris johnson
veut aller vite
win the
sun
david sassoli on veut faire traîner les
choses vraiment ici à bruxelles
non y'a bien mais nous nous sommes tout
à fait disposés à négocier nous avons
adopté des résolutions nous souhaitons
respecter les accords aftati ont été
conclus en janvier
nombe d'onagre end est un
véritable passion du côté des autorités
britanniques pour arriver à un accord et
nous en sommes désolés nous pensons
qu'il vaut mieux arriver à un accord
mais s'il n'y a pas d'accord nous nous
défendrons les principes des règles et
l'autonomie du marché européen
ça c'est notre droit et nous le
défendrons jusqu'au bout les points
d'achoppement ils sont nombreux à la
pêche les normes environnementales
fiscale sociale la question de la la
juridiction de la cour européenne de
justice si au 31 2020 en effet ledit
forcée est effectué sans accord la faute
à qui
credo qu'est
la colle pas dit qu'ils nommèrent je
pense que la faute ce serait celle de
celui qui ne fait pas tous les efforts
pour arriver à un accord nous nous
faisons tout ce qu'il faut nous avons
même sur les décors vides des
blocages opposés d'avoir quelques
moments plus vu de blocage suite à
l'accord vite nous avons demandé
quelques mois en plus pour arriver à
conclure cet accord donc la
responsabilité elle se trouve de celui
qui ne fait pas tout pour arriver à un
accord
mais notre part nous nous respectons les
décisions prises par les autorités
britanniques
tout comme nous avons respecté la
décision prise par les citoyens
britanniques
subies chanter des efforts que du côté
du
au royaume uni on est également touchée
par les contrecoups de l'aco vide
on a reçu des informations des données
économiques qui sont
voulait dire que le royaume uni durant
cette crise s'en sort finalement moins
bien sans l'union européenne que que les
27 états membres ensemble
vous savez moi je ne juge pas le royaume
uni où je prends acte de la décision
qu'ils ont prise avec
douleur nous avons dit au revoir à nos
collègues députés britanniques
évidemment chacun est libre du show
qu'il fait nous pensons qu'il vaut mieux
avoir un accord plutôt que pas d'accord
et je pense qu'il est possible d'arriver
à un accord novedia modèle du côté des
autorités britanniques nous on ne voit
pas d'enthousiasmé pour arriver à cet
accord et ça nous préoccupe bien
évidemment c'est très clair il y en a un
qui s'en réjouit cédric site en tout cas
c'est le président américain fervent
défenseur du réussite les relations
diplomatiques et commerciales avec les
états unis elles sont loin d'être simple
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire elles
se sont détériorées donald trump est ce
qu'il joue contre l'europe
ah non il continue néanmoins nous
restons convaincus on part le
multilatéralisme et le fond de rapports
les relations d'amitié avec les
etats-unis une relation historique avec
ce mardi
je pense qu'il en va de l'intérêt de
tous de renforcer cette relation mais
nous voyons également que certains par
le passé ont tenté de diviser
nous ne pouvons pas laisser passer cela
l'urgence de la pandémie qui frappe la
planète actuellement je pense que la
collaboration entre l'union européenne
et les etats unis pourrait être
un signe de force plutôt que de
faiblesses et que cela pourrait servir à
tout le monde nous nous restons
convaincus par un monde où il ya le
multilatéralisme le royaume uni qui s'en
va d'autres pays qui souhaitent intégrer
l'union européenne est ce que c'est le
bon moment notamment pour ouvrir des
négociations concrètes avec l'albanie la
macédoine et oui les europe les unionais
europe union européenne reste un pays
est un pari pour beaucoup de pays qui
souhaitent nous rejoignez nous rejoindre
oui tout à fait l'europe attire
c'est une référence
des balkans occidentaux nous les
attendons emprunt soffer nous suivons ce
qui se passe au niveau du processus
d'adhésion nous sommes battus pour
lancer ce processus avec l'albanie la
macédoine du nord hier j'ai rencontré le
premier ministre monténégrins donc d'un
pays candidat en suit leur évolution
on voit quelles sont les réformes
entreprises et nous les encourageons on
a besoin d'eux
permettra d'éclaircir la carte
géographique de l'europe de reconstruire
l'espace géopolitique ou politiques et
le faire coïncider avec l'espace
géographique et je pense que ça il en va
de l'intérêt de tout le monde est ce que
vous êtes favorable à une europe qui
serait davantage une europe à plusieurs
vitesses c'est à dire qu'il ya un socle
commun mais que des états membres ne
correspondant pas à certains critères ne
puisse pas participer à toutes les
politiques communes non non non me bat
donc c'était pas du tout quelque chose
pour laquelle je me bats moi je me bats
pour une politique commune de l'union
européenne
qui profite aux 27 états membres
ça doit être mon objectif
pour plusieurs vitesses ça impliquerait
que l'europe n'est pas en mesure de
faire face
avec un front uni aux défis qui se
posent à elle là aussi c'est très clair
alors là où l'europe a encore une très
grande marge de progression assez sur
son rayonnement de très nombreux
européens parmi lesquels les français
méconnaissent les institutions mais
aussi les personnalités européennes le
résumé en chiffres avec béatrice faisant
[Musique]
connaissez vous ce visage ou celui ci
non vous n'êtes pas seuls et cela n'a
rien à voir avec le port du masque selon
un sondage réalisé en février par
viavoice les français connaissent mal
voire très mal les personnalités
européennes sur un échantillon de 1000
personnes interrogées en ligne entre le
5 et le 7 février 2020 une petite moitié
seulement connaît l'existence de michel
barnier négociateur en chef du brésil et
de thierry breton en charge du numérique
et le chiffre ne fait que baisser dès
qu'on interroge les français sur nos
voisins européens comme ursula von der
leyen non seulement 26% prétendre la
connaître pourtant président de la
commission européenne même sort pour
charles michel président du conseil
européen connu seulement par 17% des
sondés en bas du tableau le moins connu
de tous et pourtant élu par le plus
grand nombre l italien david sassoli
président du parlement européen depuis
un an
[Musique]
david ses souliers 84% des français ne
savent pas qui vous êtes je vous ai
entendu réagir à un peu plus souvent en
france
je vous ai entendu réagir durant le
sujet vous avez dit normal c'est
embêtant de même par rapport à d'autres
institutions et des normal que le
président du parlement européen sont
moins connus mais je m'engage à venir
plus souvent en france
et on vous invite comment expliquez-vous
ce fossé entre les citoyens européens
ils union les institutions elles
paraissent si éloigné six hors de portée
que les européens ne s'y intéresse même
pas
yao kré je pense que qu'actuellement
cette tendance
n'existe pas je pense qu'il y en attente
positive et bien une attente en matière
de confiance vis-à-vis de l'europe un
grand nombre de citoyens un grand nombre
de pays ont compris que sans l'europe il
ne sera sans doute pas possible de
reconstruire leur économie
je pense que pour le moment
il ya une inversion de tendance avec une
période de confiance qui arrive
alors pour inclure les citoyens dans la
construction européenne va être lancé
d'ici la fin de l'année la conférence
sur l'avenir de l'europe l'idée intégrer
les citoyens justement au débat et le
parlement compte y tenir un rôle clé
expliquez nous comment est concrètement
ça va se passer comment cette conférence
il l'avenir et on a et on a ce qu'on
mérite ce défi de législature nous
souhaitons entamer un dialogue avec le
citoyen et citoyenne
européen avec les institutions les
parlements nationaux pour
bien définir certains mécanismes de
réforme du processus européen pauvre
rendre la démocratie européenne
plus efficace pour qu'elle soit mieux
oui lesquelles sont à moins
bureaucratique besoin de réformes
eh bien nous aussi ici à europe hebdo on
souhaite rapprocher les institutions
européennes des citoyens et nous allons
accueillir notamment un premier citoyen
c'est niklas moon qu'il est allemand il
est étudiant en journalisme
il est depuis par il a 24 ans et je
crois qu'il a une question pour vous
je me sens bien je parie
pour le mouvement blague l'animateur
mais plutôt propre du terme c'est à dire
sachant que l'union européenne et
aurillac du prix nobel de la paix des
débats depuis deux ans les femmes ont
bien des milliers de migrants dans la
mer beaucoup d'un cru temps quand même
de la commune communauté noire
je pense que l'europe sans politique
migratoire elle est faible fragile
mais ça n'aide pas nos états membres à
répondre à cette grande question qui
nous préoccupe rats pendant de
nombreuses années la question migratoire
je suis ravi d'avoir vu dans le
programme de la présidence allemande que
l'on parle de l'importance d'une
politique commune en matière
d'immigration
oui
c'est une grande bataille une bataille
de conscience et de civilisation et le
problème ce n'est pas ce pacte passé ce
péché originel ce pacte passé avec la
turquie il ya quelques années qui nous
rend dépendants
nous sommes très préoccupés par la
situation et par nos rapports avec la
turquie le parlement européen a exprimé
clairement
suffit pas de lever la voix
il ya certains éléments à respecter par
rapport à la grèce par rapport à chypre
la réponse européenne doit être très
concrète concrète
à distance toujours mais maintenant
depuis l'angleterre depuis cambridge
grégoire crêpes si les français il a 50
ans il est informaticien je crois qu'il
a une question à vous poser sans
surprise autour du bric si tu nous
écoutes
que ça se lit il y à de réelles
possibilités maintenant que l'école
devienne indépendante d'ici quelques
années à votre avis quelles sont ses
chances d'accéder à l'union européenne
assez rapidement
moi je ne veux pas me mêler des
dynamiques internes au royaume uni
vous connaissez la position du parlement
européen
nous n'avons pas stigmatisé la décision
prise à propos du président
c'est une décision qui a été prise par
les citoyens britanniques
toute évolution au sein même de l'ue ni
du royaume uni et bien nous la suivrons
attentivement
ce seront les mots de la fin merci david
celli d'avoir été notre invité
exceptionnel et on espère vous voir en
france très bientôt vous pouvez voir et
revoir cette émission replay sur le site
internet de public sénat à très bientôt
je l'espère pour de nouvelles aventures
européennes
[Musique]